the conceptualization of this component
of the symposium is that after hearing
these international legacies which I
think are very important part of what
Rwanda means today what how is the world
change because of Rwanda there is a
possibility or a risk of losing sight of
the other legacy of Rwanda which is of
the genocide that is which is a very
personal and but I guess at a national
level but reflects the sort of personal
experience the trauma that people in
that that nation experienced and perhaps
are still experiencing today and so for
that reason I wanted to have the the
second panel to be an occasion to
discuss the legacies of the genocide for
Rwanda itself primarily from the voices
of Rwanda and so i'll let i will let
Joel Zaki introduce the panel in himself
he's going to be going to be the
moderator but before we do so and I know
this is a little unusual for an academic
conference or semi academic conference
anyways is I wanted to sort I thought it
would be appropriate to have a moment to
sort of Center ourselves to Center to
the discussion to make this transition
from a panel on international affairs to
a panel on human responses to intense
trauma so I invited Jan hope Holton from
the Divinity School associate professor
professor of pastoral care and
counseling at the Divinity School to to
commence this component of the panel
with a prayer I'm not I will sort of
bare my own background here
not particularly religious myself
however I recognize and appreciate the
importance of in some way or another
taking a moment to sort of scituate
oneself when talking about issues like
this so without further ado I'd like to
invite Jan to come up here and offer
some words that may lead us to reflect a
bit and then from Jan we will turn over
11 little bit of further ado to joel's a
key who is you can read his bio in the
handout but he's the special adviser and
genocide education at the Greenberg
Center of the University of Hartford and
who has been working over the past 18
months or longer longer longer than 18
months with the the Ministry of
Education in Rwanda on a project that is
redesigning how how they how the Rwandan
education system works and how the
genocide is dealt with within Rwanda as
well so first Jan then Joe thank you
so invite you if you are comfortable to
do so to pray with me if you prefer to
receive these words as words of
meditation please do that as well o God
of mercy we gather today in a season of
mourning and remembrance to honor the
victims of the genocide in Rwanda 20
years ago a terrible moment in the arc
of human history when the earth was
soaked with unspeakable violence the
heavens gasped as hand and weapon were
raised against sister and brother in a
flurry of hatred and fear your divine
heart O God was wrenched into by the
brutal murder and suffering of so many
of your children today most of us
remember the death inflicted as a number
beyond comprehension but you remember
each beloved soul by name as they
breathe their last in this moment of
silence we honor those who died and we
remember their story
in your mercy hear our prayer god of
courage we give you thanks and ask your
blessing on the survivors who so
courageously continue to tell their
story especially those whose voices
speak today may we show a similar
courage to hear these stories of
unbearable suffering so that we too
might help carry the mantle forward as
ones who vow to remember may it be their
resilience that compels our memory and
Spurs us into action in this moment of
silence we honor the survivors
especially those who continue to suffer
and we remember their story
in your mercy hear our prayers o God of
justice too often we have chosen to
ignore that we are citizens in a global
community brothers and sisters in our
humanity bind us o God with your justice
so as not to forget our moral moral
obligation to care for the other whether
near or far never never let us stand
idle either in the face of fear and
hatred nor the atrocities to which they
give birth in this moment we will
consider our promise to be partners in
vigilance and action toward against such
atrocities
god of Hope through the dirt though the
journey has been long your love helps
heal a land that once ran red with blood
your grace allows song to again claimed
the skies they were once filled with
cries of suffering you have painted a
future for a people once lost to its
passed through you they have risen to
claim reconciliation over revenge peace
over violence healing over harm love
over hatred today we remember them amen
welcome to the panel discussion on the
legacies of genocide in Rwanda today one
defines itself in a crossroads moving
from the humanitarian assistance phase
associated with the 1994 genocide into
one of sustainable development since
1994 the government of rwanda has
stabilized the political situation
whilst putting the economy back on track
with considerable assistance from
development partners however the
challenges remain daunting this
afternoon with this esteemed panel we
will be discussing the legacies of
genocide in Rwanda I'd like to introduce
the panel first we have the second
counselor from the Rwandan Embassy to
the United States yevette rogowska hunga
the second is mr. Steve Krause filmmaker
and third is consul a Nisshin way who is
a survivor and also an author like to
welcome after the opening statements by
our panelists we would will delve into
the subject of the genocide the legacies
of genocide in Rwanda would like to go
first
you